eating salad can often feel like a chore
or a punishment especially when you
don't know the first thing about how to
make one but we're here to show you that
would a little planning you can build a
salad that you're not only going to want
to eat but look forward to the main
problem people face when making a salad
is that they're either too boring or
overloaded with toppings that don't go
together so we are here to help you find
a middle ground every salad should have
seven components greens protein a carve
veggies and fruit if you want something
creamy or fatty something crunchy and a
flavor punch so let's start with the
greens here we have mescaline spinach
arugula and kale choosing a variety of
greens is going to make yoursel it more
interesting so we're going to add some
spinach and arugula some mix things up
now moving on to protein here we have
chicken Victo fuu or boiled eggs and
shrimp
you could add any protein you like
adding protein to salad is super
important because it's just going to
fill you up and it's the weight can
really turn a salad into a meal today
we're in the mood for chicken now for
the car stick with carbs like sweet
potatoes chickpeas quinoa or black beans
try to include complex carbs like whole
grains or beans to give you a
long-lasting energy and avoid white
flours like pasta for veggies and fruits
tried tomatoes bell peppers cucumbers
apples or carrots it's okay to add a few
of these these will help fill your salad
out and also make sure you're eating the
rainbow now for some crunch there are so
many options like sesame sticks pepitas
walnuts croutons or even crispy fried
onions adding some crunch is going to
give your salad some texture and liven
things up finally we have to add our
flavor punch like fresh herbs sun-dried
tomatoes pomegranate seeds or olives
this is what's going to give yourself
that wow factor but you also want to
make sure you don't overload on these
because they can definitely clash
and now it's time to make our
vinaigrette so to make a vinaigrette you
really only need four ingredients oil
acid and emulsifier and seasoning first
we're going to combine our acid and
emulsifier we're going with red wine
vinegar for an acid and Dijon mustard
for an emulsifier next you're going to
stream in your oil of choice as you
whisk everything together incorporating
the oil slowly and including an
emulsifier it will prevent the oil and
acid from separating for our seasoning
we're going with salt pepper and dried
oregano but the possibilities here are
endless get crazy and experiment with
different flavor combinations because a
delicious vinaigrette can really take a
salad to the next level and that's all
there is to it
then the grits are super easy to make
and by preparing them yourself you'll
know exactly what's in them the key to
keeping solids from getting boring
is switching them up so even if you find
a flavor combination you love keep
trying new ingredients and keep
experimenting and before you know it you
may even find that salad has become
something you're craving
[Music]
[Music]
you